enfin bon merci mesdames d'être là nous
poursuivons donc les travaux de la
commission d'enquête sur les moyens
mobilisés et mobilisables par l'État
pour assurer la prise en compte et le
respect par le groupe Total énergie des
obligation climatique et des
orientations de la politique étrangère
de la France dans ce cadre nous
entendons aujourd'hui madame Orianne
Wegner cofondatrice du collectif éclairc
et de la plateforme
carbonbombs.org et Madame louvelgreen
analyste au sein du carbone 4 finances
co-président de l'association data forg
la plateforme carbon bombs a identifié
des bombes carbon c'est-à-dire des
projets pétroliers ou gaziers
particulièrement
émissif avant de vous laisser la parole
pour un propos introductif d'une dizaine
de minutes chacune il me revient de vous
indiquer que cette audition est diffusée
en direct et en différée sur le site
internet du Sénat
la vidéo sera le cas échéant diffusée
sur les réseaux sociaux puis consultable
en vidéo à la demande elle fera
naturellement l'objet d'un compte-rendu
publié je rappelle en outre qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête est passible des peines
prévues aux articles 434 13 14 et 15 du
code pénal qui peuvent aller de 3 à 7
ans d'emprisonnement de 45000 à 100000 €
d'amende je vous invite maintenant a
prêté cement de dire toute la vérité Ren
que la vérité en levant la main droite
et en disant je le
jure
merci merci avant de vous céder la
parole je vous invite à nous préciser si
vous détenez des intérêts de toute
nature dans le groupe Total ennergie ou
inversement si je puiss dire chez l'un
de ses concurrents dans le secteur de
l'énergie compris sous forme de
prestation de conseil de participation à
des cénacles financés par par des
énergéticiens
oui mais si vous pouvez mettre le micro
chaque je détiun merci je n'en détiens
aucun non plus merci votre réponse sera
naturellement mentionnée au
compte-rendu je vous laisse dans
l'immédiat faire l'introduction que vous
souhaitez et ensuite vous répondrez aux
questions
merci peut-être juste une question avant
que je commence avec mon propre propos
limininaire est-ce que du coup on peut
compter sur les slides
un technicien va
arriver
d'accord je vais commencer du coup en en
attendant le la présentation et
puis on complétera ensuite bon ça ça ira
très bien même sans lesesside pour
démarer donc la première chose c'est
donc voilà Louvel Green et Orian weegner
toutes les deux coautrices de de cette
étude qui a été publiée fin octobre sur
ce qu'on appelle les projets de bombe
carbone dont don on va parler un peu
plus longuement aujourd'hui donc
peut-être un un propos introductif avant
d'entrer dans le vif du sujet nous notre
constat à l'origine le constat qui est
qui est donc à l'origine de ce travail
c'est qu'on est actuellement pris en
tenail entre deux certitudes la première
certitude c'est le fait que l'année 2023
est la plus chaude qui a été enregistrée
au cours de ces 40 dernières années et
la deuxième certitude c'est que c'est
aussi vraisem vraisemblablement la plus
froide des 40 années à venir partant de
ce
constatl on note quand même le fait que
de nouveaux projets
pétrogaziers continuent à être lancés
euh chaque année euh malgré donc c cet
état de de d'urgence climatique certain
donc nous notre notre constat notre
approche ça a été une démarche qui est à
la fois scientifique et citoyenne qui
est une démarche qui est portée par deux
collectifs par deux organisations la
première s'appelle éclairci la deuxième
s'appelle data for good donc éclairci
c'est une c'est une structure qui a été
créée en 2022 qui rassemble des experts
des questions climatiques et
environnementales des chercheurs des
ingénieurs des économistes et qui
ensemble travaille à rendre le plus
clair et intelligible possible les
données complexes la profusion de
données complexes disponibles sur les
enjeux environnementaux data forg c'est
un collectif de plusieurs milliers de
bénévoles du secteur de la technologie
data analyst data scientist qui mettent
leur compétences au service du bien
commun eu donc ça c'est pour qui a
travaillé ensuite la question c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait et comment on l'a
fait donc notre travail ça a été de
mettre en relation trois bases de
données qui étaient publiques donc ces
trois bases de données là la première
c'est un article de recherche qui a été
publié en 2022 par un chercheur qui
s'appelleelcune et ses co-auteurs et qui
fait une cartographie de ce qu'on
appelle donc les bombes carbones on y on
reviendra à la définition dans une
minute donc de ces 425 plus gros projet
d'extraction fossile dans le monde donc
on a pris cette première base de données
et on l'a mise en lien avec deux autres
base de données la deuxième c'est une
base de données qui s'appelle global
energy monitor qui est une base de
données qui fait référence dans le
secteur et qui fait le lien entre les
projets et les entreprises qui
exploitent ces projets et ensuite la
dernière partie de not travail pour
donner un panorama complet de la
responsabilité des des États qui sont
engagés dans dans ces projets dans ces
énormes projets de d'extraction c'est
une troisème base de données euh issu
d'un consortium deong qui s'appelle
banking on climate chaos et qui fait le
lien entre euh les entreprises qui
exploitent ces projets et les banques
qui les financent donc si on fait le
lien des trois ça nous fait un un
panorama général euh des différentes
responsabilités qui permettent que ces
projets soient encore exploités donc
euh pour revenir rapidement sur la
définition de bombe carbone et bon il y
a il y a une carte qui apparaîtra
peut-être un jour donc on a 425 projets
dans le monde euh on y reviendra un peu
plus tard ils sont répartis un peu
partout sur le globe
avec quand même une on le verra un peu
plus tard une responsabilité assez
majeure en tout cas ils sont implantés
de manière prédominante dans certains
lieux notamment aux États-Unis en Chine
dans le golfe Persique mais mais on y
reviendra ce qui est important c'est de
savoir que il y a toute une partie de
ces projet qui n'a pas encore démarré
qui sont des projets qui sont encore en
cours de développement ou qui sont
simplement à l'état de projet ça veut
dire qu'on donc on continue à à faire le
projet de de nouveaux projets
pétrogazier euh
[Musique]
il y a il y a un chiffre qui nous semble
particulièrement important à souligner
et qui nécessite de faire un un retour
rapide sur donc la notion de de budget
carbone de laquelle vous êtes peut-être
déjà familier mais mais qui est vraiment
très importante à à souligner à rappeler
pour comprendre vraiment le le les
enjeux de ce travail donc le budget
carbone c'est la somme totale des
émissions qu'on peut relâcher dans
l'atmosphère avant de d'arriver à un
certain stade de échauffement donc nous
notre point de référence ce sur quoi on
a travaillé c'est le budget carbone 1
der5 et si on fait la somme des émission
qui pourrait être généré par tous les
projets tous ces projets de bombe
carbone à la fois les existants et les
projets avenir ceux qui sont encore dans
un stade de démarrage on excède le
budget carbone 1 der 5 par un facteur 2
à 3 vraiment je me permets d'insister
parce que c'est extrêmement important ça
veut dire que si ces projets vont tous
jusqu'au bout euh on on comment dire on
dépasse extrêmement largement les
limites des émissions qu'on peut générer
pour espérer rester dans un dans un
scénario 1 degr 5 donc ça c'est vraiment
le le constat fondamental à avoir en
tête et c'est et c'est l'une des choses
sur lesquelles on souhaite mettre
l'accent pour détailler un peu cette
question là de du fait que ces projets
donc dépassent excèdent les engagements
climatiques mondiaux et ceux de la
France aussi a on peut revenir aussi sur
une déclaration du directeur exécutif de
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie qui
date de
2021 au cours de laquelle donc Fati
barol disait que si pour le citer c'est
si les gouvernements veulent être
sérieux au sujet de la crise
climatique il ne devrait y avoir aucun
nouvel investissement dans des projets
d'extraction à partir de l'année
or on le verra un peu plus tard sur des
graphes or ce qui est ce qui est
vraiment important à voir c'est que donc
nous il y a il y a à peu près 40 % des
projets de notre base de données qui
n'ont pas encore démarré qui sont donc
des décisions d'invest enfin qui sont
typiquement des des projet post 2021
donc cette nature de projet qui est
censé être exclu de de des scénarios de
neutralité
euh
ah
donc je vais profiter de du fait que les
slides apparaissent pour pouvoir vous
montrer un graphe sur les les les
scénarios de neutralité de
laie bon peu importe
[Musique]
euh voilà donc je je fais un un petit
retour rapide si tu veux bien revenir à
la slide juste avant voilà euh avant
précédente voilà exactement ça c'est
c'est exactement ce que j'essayais de
vous dire tout à l'heure donc sur le le
budget carbone ce que vous voyez à
gauche ce sont donc les émissions
générées par tous nos projets donc ceux
qui n'ont pas encore démarré et ceux qui
vont démarrer et à droite en ver le
budget carbon 1 degr 5 donc si on passe
à la slide suivante c'est le propos que
j'étais en train de de développer euh
sur donc le le budget carbone euh les
émissions générées par les projets
actuellement en cours sur le la la
grande bar bar de gauche et au milieu
sur ceux qui n'ont pas encore démarré et
là-dessus donc vous voyez de deux types
de couleurs en bleu sombre les projet
oil and gaz les projets pétrole et gaz
et en en rose en violet les projets de
charbon donc voilà ça ça illustre
typiquement le le propos qu'on tenait
tout à l'heure sur la quantité
d'émissions à venir euh si on passe sur
la slide suivante euh là ce que vous
voyez c'est un scénario donc le scénario
de référence net zéro émission qu'on
appellera le scénario nz2 de l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie ce qui est
extrêmement important à comprendre de ce
graphique c'est de regarder tout d'abord
l'air grise donc l'air qui est qui
apparaît plutôt rose à l'écran l'air
basse qui est donc les les champs en
production et les champs en cours de
développement et surtout cette ligne
violette qui est la trajectoire net zéro
de la donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut retenir
de ça il faut retenir que ces budgets
ces ces projets de bombe carbone ont
deux caractéristiques la première chose
c'est c'est qu'ils sont superflu par
rapport à ce cette trajectoire net zéro
de l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
et la deuxième donc c'est ce qu'on a dit
tout à l'heure c'est qu'en plus ils sont
néfastes au sens où ils mettent en
danger notre capacité à atteindre nos
nos engagements climatiques donc ils
sont à la fois pas nécessaires et en
même temps dangereux du point de vue de
nos engagements climatiques
euh sur la slide suivante
eu on
peut donc parler à un moment de la
responsabilité des acteurs je pense
qu'il a l'une des questions qui va
particulièrement nous occuper
aujourd'hui donc il y a trois types
d'acteurs notamment qui sont
particulièrement
euh on peut dire à la source à l'origine
impliqué dans ces projets de bombe
carbone donc il y a les banques les
entreprises et les assurances donc les
entreprise je vais pas le développer
parce que je laisserai loup en parler
tout à l'heure notamment avec
l'illustration du cadre total ennergie
en revanche je peux vous parler des
banques qui ont un rôle absolument
majeur dans donc le financement de ces
projets et ce qui est important à noter
c'est le fait que les banques peuvent
financer les projets par par deux canaux
un premier canal qui est ce qu'on
appelle le financement général le
financement corporate qui est une nature
de financement donc quand quand une
banque accorde par exemple un prêt à
l'entreprise sans le flécher directement
vers un projet et la deuxième chose
c'est ce qu'on appelle le financement de
projet donc c'est une banque qui
s'engage directement à financer un
projet particulier par exemple d'une
entreprise d'hydrocarbure ça c'est
important à savoir on en redisutera plus
tard quand on réfléchit à la
réglementation de ces investissements la
réglementation des accords financiers
euh parce qu'il faut bien avoir à
l'esprit que il est difficile de flécher
euh la manière dont le le l'argent
accordé par les banques et ensuite
alloué au sein de l'entreprise euh donc
simplement pour finir et avant de passer
la la parole à loup euh sur la slide
suivante
euh on peut aborder aussi une question
je pense qu'on on aura vraiment
largement l'occasion d'y revenir plus
tard dans la commission c'est le rôle
des États dans ces dans ces projets
d'extraction donc nous on n' pas de de
données chiffrées là-dessus parce que
nos trois bases de données n'incluent
pas le rôle des États malgré ça on
travaillant sur ces projets donc on a
largement creusé le sujet donc il y a
peut-être deux choses qu'on peut mettre
en avant dans le rôle des États et qu'on
pourra développer par la suite la
première chose c'est la question de
l'environnement réglementaire donc
l'État ont un rôle une forme de
responsabilité aussi dans ces projets
d'extraction par le le l'environnement
réglementaire soit sur leur sol soit
pour les entreprises de les activités à
l'étr
des entreprises ressortissantes du
territoire national ça c'est la première
chose et la deuxième chose dont on
reparlera aussi peut-être plus tard
c'est la question des financements
directs et indirect accordé par les
États aux entreprises pétroggasières je
vais m'arrêter ici et laisser la parole
à Lou qui va vous parler plus longuement
donc de de la question du rôle des
entreprises et en particulier dans le
casadre
totalénergie bonjour Merci beaucoup donc
maintenant l'idée c'est de faire un un
focus sur l'entreprise Total ennergie et
en particulier en commençant par Total
énergie dans la base de données des
bombes carbon donc sur la base de
données on dénombre 23 bombes carbon
auquel total énergie est associé ce qui
sont des bombes carbones qui auraient
des émissions potentiel associé de 60
gigatonnes de CO2 donc pour revenir très
rapidement sur la méthodologie on a
considéré parce qu'on n pas dans une
démarche de comptabilité carbone stricte
mais dans une démarche de vulgarisation
euh et aussi parce que à partir du
moment où une entreprise est impliquée
dans un projet elle permet à ce projet
d'exister euh on a euh délibérément pour
toutes les entreprises euh conserver
l'intégralité des émissions euh dans une
démarche vraiment de vulgarisation donc
si euh on essaie de faire un focus sur
quelques projets pour vous présenter un
peu la diversité euh des projets de la
stratégie euh de Total énergie euh un
des premiers projets dont on ah oui donc
on voit pas très bien euh à cause des
couleurs un des projets un des premiers
projets dont on voulait vous parler
c'est par exemple le projet de norsfield
qui est un projet à la fois auou total à
des participations anciennes dans les
champs Dolphine et catargas 2 mais qui
vient aussi très dernièrement d'être
sélectionné dans un projet d'extension
de Northfield South avec une
participation de 9,3 % à peu près euh
sur les 25 % qui sont proposés aux
partenaires internationaux en 2022 ce
qui en fait le premier partenaire
international et cette cette
participation elle a été enterinée en
2022 ce qui est intéressant sur ce sujet
c'est que norsfield c'est beaucoup c'est
un champ où il va y avoir beaucoup de
production de GNL donc le GNL pour
revenir très rapidement sur ce que c'est
le GNL c'est un type de gaz qui est
composé à 90 % de méthane qui a un gaz à
qui a un pouvoir de réchauffement qui
est 30 fois supérieur au CO2 sur 100 ans
en fait c'est une une nouvelle manière
de transporter du gaz donc on le compare
aux gazoducs internationaux donc vous
voyez qui est le le premier graphique et
en dessous en fait on peut voir qu'il y
a beaucoup plus d'étapes de
transformation pour produire du gaz
naturel liquéfié notamment en fait on
doit passer par une table de
purification puis de li de liquéfaction
on le on le transforme à une température
de -160° pour pouvoir le transporter sur
des méthaniers puis le regazéifier
toutes ces étapes de transformation en
fait elles vont avoir beaucoup de
mission donc
euh par
exemple par exemple d'après des calculs
de carbone 4 on voit que le gaz naturel
liqufié est au moins 2,5 fois plus
émetteur sur les émissions Amon qui
représente à peu près 14 % des émissions
du gaz que le gaz transporté par
gazoduc euh donc ensuite si on passe à
un autre type de projet euh plutôt là
dans la catégorie des nouveaux projets
qui n'ont pas encore commencé on peut
évoquer le projet du le projet
Mozambique GNL donc qui est également un
projet de euh avec qui contient des des
trains de liqufaction pour produire du
GNL euh ce qu'on sait de ce projet c'est
qu'en 2021 il a été suspendu pour quatre
forces majeures suite à une attaque
dihadiste et qu'il y a un recours en
cours pour homicideun volontaire
concernant qui concerne totel et qu'en
septembre 2023 totel a annoncé vouloir
relancer le projet euh alors que il est
encore la zone n'est pas encore
stabilisée et qu'il il est décrit
actuellement par de nombreuses euh ONG
et enfin si on prend un projet de type
plutôt non conventionnel euh on peut
parler du projet euh vakaarta qui est
euh localisé en Patagonie donc cette
bombe carbone qui pourrait
potentiellement émettre 5,58 gatonn de
CO2 donc pourquoi est-ce que c'est
intéressant de parler de celui-là aussi
c'est parce que c'est un autre type
d'extraction donc là on va parler de euh
fracture hydraulique euh en fait ça veut
dire que contrairement à un réservoir
classique comme vous voyez sur le schéma
là on va vraiment aller euh extraire euh
du gaz euh de manière beaucoup plus qui
est présent de manière beaucoup plus
diffuse et donc ça va nécessiter de
fracturer la roche euh ça va avoir comme
impact qu' ça va requérir beaucoup plus
de d'énergie euh mais également euh ça
va avoir des rejets de méthane euh
beaucoup plus importants euh par rapport
au conventionnel donc par exemple il y a
une étude euh chinoise dans Nature
communication qui a été publiée en 2020
euh qui a montré que l'extraction de gaz
de schiste est quatre fois plus émissive
que celle du gaz conventionnel avec 50 à
70 % des émissions qui sont liées au gaz
de méthane au fut de méthane pardon donc
c'est important à avoir en tête et puis
a également le le fait que ça pose des
questions de gestion d'eau et de qualité
de l'air
euh donc donc voilà on a fait à peu près
le le tour des projets donc il y en a 23
avec chacun des caractéristiques
différentes mais c'était pour illustrer
la diversité des types de projets
d'extraction qui peuvent expliquer qui
peuvent exister sur la base de données
euh un autre point qu'on voulait vous
souligner c'était du coup comme l'a
mentionné Orian précédemment la question
des financements donc on sait que depuis
l'accord de Paris total energy a reçu 52
milliards d'euros des 60 plus grandes
banques euh mondial ce chiffre a été
calculé par banking on climate chaos
dont d'ailleurs 18 milliards des plus
grandes banques françaises et donc ce
chiffre il peut interroger et ouvrir la
porte sur la question vraiment de la
réglementation à mettre en place euh au
niveau des acteurs financiers euh pour
les faire contribuer également à la
transition énergétique
euh enfin euh pour finir je pas dans le
bon sens pour finir euh on voulait euh
tous ces tous ces projets de bombe
carbone en fait il posent la question
plus générale du positionnement du
groupe vis-à-vis de la la transition
énergétique mondiale euh et de leur
propre stratégie de décarbonation donc
cet enjeu il est cristallisé dans le le
slogan de total energy qui est une
compagnie net z0ro en 2050 ensemble avec
la société euh donc quand on se quand on
quand on voit ce slogan la question qu'
qu'on peut se poser c'est euh euh au
niveau de des émission net zéro donc que
vaut la stratégie de décarbonation avec
s'interroger sur la question du
reporting des objectifs de la question
du passage par rapport à la trajectoire
et des allégations de net zéro euh et
qu'est-ce qu'on veut dire avec ensemble
avec la société comment est-ce que cette
cette définition elle s'insère dans la
société de demain à la fois en terme
d'offre et à la fin en terme de demande
d'énergie et on pourra en reparler plus
plus en détail si vous le souhaitez par
la
suite et pour finir je voulais juste
prendre un tout petit peu plus de
hauteur avec un graphique très
intéressant qui montre la répartition
des dépenses de l'industrie
pétroggazière en général en sur la
période 2012-2022 donc pour sortir un
peu uniquement du de Total mais
regardeer l'industrie en général ce
qu'on voit quand on regarde les dépenses
de l'industrie c'est déjà ce qui saute
aux yeux c'est l'augmentation
progressive des dividends et rachats
d'action au cours du temps mais
également on sait que dans les périodes
2021 2022 il y a eu une explosion des
bénéfices de ces entreprises or on
constate qu'il y a très peu
d'augmentation des investissements bas
carbon euh on voit une part très faible
en fait de de de de de C dépense qui va
aux énergies bacarbon par contre on voit
l'apparition du du remboursement de la
dette on peut vraiment s'interroger sur
la répartition des flux financiers et le
fait que cette explosion des profits n'a
pas permis d'augmenter la part des
investissements bas carbone euh voilà
merci
beaucoup le dernier tableau je comprends
bien que c'est l'industrie pétroggazière
dans le monde oui nor puisque c'est la
c'est pasou exactement c'est pas spécifi
total ou les industries françaises merci
mesdames avant de céder la parole au
rapporteur puis à chacun de nos
collègues euh nous avons
jusqu'à
11h45 jusqu'à
11h45 avant le l'intervention suivante
euh moi je voudrais vous dire j'entends
bien ce que vous
dites vous dites bah légisement déjà en
exercice
suffise mais comment vous réglez le
problème des états qui émergant ou pas
d'ailleurs qui ont des
gisements j'allais presque dire pour
certains d'entre eux qui n'ont que ça et
qui disent bah vous êtes bien aimable
vous avez déjà vous votre développement
et nous nous nous en sortons comment
parce que vous nous dites euh on ouvre
plus de gisement de pétrole on nouvre
plus de gisement de gaz
euh nous si on a que ça comme ressources
euh on voudrait bien les valoriser et
les vendre donc pour avoir les moyens de
développement donc de ce côté-là il y a
quand même un problème permanent les
utilisateurs c'est l'Occident les
producteurs aimerait bien aussi avoir
une part de la manne quoi mais alors
comment on règle ça parce que si vous me
répondez que il suffit que l'Occident
fasse des transferts financiers ça va
pas se faire facilement hein donc ça
c'est un peu compliqué mais j'aimerais
avoir votre avis là-dessus deuxième
élément vous vous parlez par exemple
de du champ de norfield au tard si je ne
m'abuse et or total énergie est
effectivement impliqué dans ce champ
mais il y a shell il y a Qatar ennergie
est-ce que si total énergie n'était pas
là bon le Qatar ferait pas quand même ce
gisement bah avec son entreprise
nationale et avec Shelle est-ce que ce
que je veux dire c'est que on fait pas
le procès de total on essaie de
comprendre d'abord comment on peut
avancer sur les choses et applique qui
est effectivement la transition
mais il y a pas d'autorité enfin il y a
laie mais est-ce que il y a une autorité
internationale susceptible de faire une
répartition
ou un élément cadrant un peu tout le
monde parce que si chaque fois qu'on dit
quelque chose on nous dit bah si c'est
pas total c'est Shelle si c'est pas
total c'est exon si c'est pas total on
est un peu court dans vos réflexions et
dans vos analyses est-ce que vous avez
avancé là-dessus
et fait des propositions ou trouver des
solutions j'en sais rien est-ce que vous
avez des choses là-dessus merci merci
monsieur le Président pour votre
question je vais peut-être commencer à
donner une première réponse et ensuite
le complètera certainement la première
question sur effectivement comment on
résout la Grande Équation de la de la
transition mondiale entre le fait qu'il
aura forcément des perdants et comment
est-ce qu'on on fait en sorte d'avoir
une coordination internationale
suffisante pour que la transition ait
bien lieu effectivement c'est une
question qui est extrêmement
intéressante qui est très importante à
ma connaissance qui est pas complètement
résolue le rôle des transferts est
absolument central euh à la question de
est-ce que ça va suffire comment
contraindre les États à le faire là pour
le coup ça ça dépasse le cadre de notre
travail même si effectivement c'est une
réflexion qu'il faut mener en parallèle
la seule chose qu'on peut dire là-dessus
c'est le fait que c'est c'est l'un des
objectifs des COP au cours des dernières
années que la COP 29 à venir cette année
sera particulèrement financière et donc
que ça fait partie des des questions
qu'il faut se poser et ça fait
d'ailleurs partie de de l'article le de
de l'accord de Paris de mon souvenir
mettre en cohérence les flux financiers
avec les
objectifs climatiques effectivement ça
fait partie des des
gros s'en occuper et tout elle va être à
bacoup en Azerbaïdjan vous pensez que
ils vont être très tentés de dire alors
que même surt une puissance pétrolière
que ils vont ils vont vouloir des
mesures fortes c'est effectivement une
question qui se pose et à la fois on a
eu une COP cette année à Dubaï on peut
pas dire que ce soit un succès absolu il
y a quand même eu des on a quand même
mis tout le monde autour de la table et
je pense qu'on on peut pas partir
perdant à l'avance sur cette COP parce
que le fait d'avoir tout le monde tous
les états ensemble pour discuter euh
c'est c'est déjà une première étape bon
après effectivement le le discuter de si
la COP 29 permettra ou pas de mettre en
œuvre le financement nécessaire ça pour
le coup ça euh dépasse le cadre de notre
projet même si je pense que c'est
effectivement une question qu'il faut
traiter euh à votre deuxième question
que je trouve effectivement absolument
centrale
surtout dans une commission qui
s'intéresse au rôle de Total ennergie si
total abandonné mettons du jour au
lendemain l'intégralité de ses projet
est-ce qu'on serait pour autant avancé
est-ce que ce serait une solution sur du
point de vue de la du réchauffement
global effectivement le l'argument que
vous avancez celui de dire si c'est pas
total ce sera une autre entreprise
spontanément c'est évidemment une chose
à laquelle on pense néanmoins je pense
qu'il il y a quelque chose il y a une
réponse qui est assez intéressante de ce
point de vue-l et qui a a été apporté
par le le tribunal de la ha euh en 2021
dans mon souvenir dans le cadre du
contentieux qui a opposé les ONG à
l'entreprise shell justement sur la
question de la mise en cohérence de ce
de sa stratégie avec les objectifs
climatiques et ce qui est extrêmement
intéressant c'est que Shell dans ses
dans sa défense avait mis sur la table
exactement l'argument que vous citez
c'est-à-dire ça sert à rien de nous
interdire de de nous de nous traîner
nous interdire nous puisque si c'est pas
nous qui le faisons ce sera n'importe
quel autre concurrent et donc ça ne sert
à rien le juge répond à ça le juge fait
fait une une réponse qui est quand même
assez intéressante qui
est la première chose c'est que le
tribunal retient le fait qu'il y a pas
de preuve que d'autres entreprises que
Shelle reprendrai le rôle d'autant plus
si on réfléchit en terme de de
transition globale si on réfléchit dans
le cadre de la transition de l'Union
européenne de la transition des
États-Unis dans dans la mesure des
politiques de de décarbonation qui sont
mises en place si on réfléchit
simplement en terme sur le périmètre de
la France enfin si on arrête de
réfléchir strictement du périmètre de la
France et qu'on élargit à l'effort euh
de décarbonation qui est à cours dans le
Nord global on peut imaginer que ce soit
des des politiques de transition que
soit des décisions contraignantes qui
soient prises qui soient généralisé et
et qui qui aboutissent à contraindre
finalement euh euh une plus grande
partie des entreprises pétroggazières
basées dans les les pays du Nord ça
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est que le juge et et je pense
que c'est important de le souligner le
juge dit que même si Shelle ne peut pas
résoudre à lui tout seul le problème
global du changement climatique il ne
faut pas pour autant l'absoudre de sa
responsabilité et ça je pense que ça
peut faire partie des choses dont on
discute aussi dans le casadre total
c'est même si l'objet n'est pas de dire
que Total est une entreprise qui porte à
elle toute seule l'intégralité de la
responsabilité du changement climatique
néanmoins elle emporte une petite partie
et je pense que c'est de ça qu'on
discute aujourd'hui
monsieur le
rapporteur merci merci pour votre
intervention et pour la la qualité de
vos travaux ce qu'on voit depuis le
début de ces auditions
c'est dans le discours politique général
l'idée c'est la neutralité carbone à
2050 ou à
2040 c'est ce que portent aussi leurs
entreprises c'est de dire au fond quel
sera le point
d'arrivée ce qu'on a parfait vu avec
tous les experts climatiques et
pétroliers c'est la question du budget
carbone parce qu'au fond évidemment
c'est pas simplement le point d'arrivée
qui compte c'est comment on y arrive et
ce qu'avait dit particulièrement madame
maçonm c'est de dire en
réalité aujourd'hui on a 250 gigatonn de
budget carbone si on veut rester sur 1,5
donc elle avait réduit c'est les travaux
du JEC le budget carbone disponible et
ce que vous nous dites c'est que les 23
bombes carbone euh dans lesquelles total
est impliqué c'est 60 gatonn 60 Gat sur
250 Gat c'est 25 % de du budget carbone
donc effectivement on est là sur des
ampleurs qui qui nous invitent à à à
réfléchir deuxièmement euh euh euh
évidemment la question euh si c'est pas
total c'est d'autres c'est aussi c'est
pas simplement neutralisé total sur ou
les compagnies sur le pétrole ou le gaz
c'est qu'est-ce qu'elle pourrait faire
d'autre parce qu'il est évident que ce
gaz notamment répond à des besoins
croissants en électricité et que si ces
entreprises mettaient leur puissance
financière le leur capacité d'ingénierie
et d'investissement sur d'autres
réponses à nos besoins on aurait aurait
aussi moins besoin de ces bombes carbone
moi j'aurais juste deux questions au
fond je vais vous renvoyer la question
que vous posez à la fin de votre
intervention que vaut la stratégie
décarbonation de Total au regard de de
ces budgets carbon que vous nous avez
proposé et puis c'est évidemment très
fortement la question du du
GNL on voit se multiplier les projets
GNL dans la fusion d'ailleurs des gaz
conventionnels et des gaz de schiste
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
peu plus comment le GNL qui pour Total
est considéré comme une énergie pas
carbone est un problème pour le climat
ou une partie de la solution comme le
prétend
total euh merci beaucoup pour la
question
euh donc sur la stratégie de totel on
avait préparé quelques éléments
euh que je vais vous montrer dès
maintenant du coup si on répond sur la
stratégie totale je pense que ce qui est
important c'est déjà de regarder la
photographie actuelle en fait où on en
est en 2024 par rapport à là où il faut
aller donc aujourd'hui total
ennergie donc a une production
d'électricité renouvelable qui
représente dans son énergie totale
environ 1 % donc c'est dire que 99 % est
de l'énergie fossile en ce qui concerne
la les CAPEX donc les investissements
les dépenses liées à l'investissement
par opposition aux investissements de
fonctionnement ils sont autour de 25 %
dans le bac carbone donc ce qui veut
dire qu'il y a encore 75 % des
investissements qui sont liés aux
énergies fossiles et ce qui est
important de rappeler également c'est
que aujourd'hui total Energie est
l'entreprise qui a mené le plus
d'activités d'exploration pétrolière
dans le monde en 2022 d'après la liste
eurgovald donc ça c'est la photographie
actuelle la question maintenant c'est
quel est où est-ce qu'on va et comment
est-ce qu'on y va donc si on s'arrête
d'abord sur les objectifs juste
excusez-moi vous pouvez vous pouvez
préciser ce qui est bas
carbone ce qui
est ce que vous appelez bas carbone ce
que vous dites 25 % bas carbone 75 %
fossile ou si le gaz est dans le bas
carbone c'est quand même une énergie
fossile non non là c'est vraiment plutôt
des investissements dans les énergies
vertes le développement de renouvelable
et
cetera c'est marqué vous avez là le
le
pardon total pardon est-ce que Total est
à 25 % aujourd'hui en en renouvelable
bon je j'ai pas le chiffre précédent
mais je pourrais vous l'envoyer parce
que si vous nous dites que ça a doublé
en 5 ans ils sont sur la bonne voie si
vous nous dites que ça a pas bougé alors
il y a un problème
oui% oui bon les av al quand on parle de
CAPEX on parle de flux et les 1 % c'est
du stock donc en fait c'est pour ça que
c'est pas exactement on c'est pas c'est
pas comparable euh exactement euh et je
vous enverrai le les chiffres précédents
euh sur l'année 2030 euh donc là en fait
l'idée c'est de montrer en fait la
stratégie d'évolution de de total donc
là c'est un extrait euh de euh son euh
de son rapport de de sustainability donc
ce qu'on voit euh c'est que Total va
mettre en œuvre une réduction euh des
produits pétroliers à horizon 2030 mais
qu'en fait cette cette diminution de des
produits pétroliers elle est compensée
par la hausse de la vente du GNL donc
qui reste et donc ça c'est vraiment très
important de le préciser le le gaz
naturel liquefié reste une énergie
fossile et n'est donc pas une énergie de
transition comme c'est présenté par
Total énergie et ce qu'on voit
finalement si on fait le bilan entre
2015 et 2030 sur le scope 3 donc je sais
pas si le scope 3 vous avez besoin d'un
rappel rapide euh dans
le en fait les émissions scope 1 et 2
sont liés à
l'énergie et les émissions scope 3
représentent toutes les émissions qui
sont liées au cycle de vie amont et aval
de la création d'un produit donc quand
on parle d'énergie fossile il faut
savoir que le scope 3 ça représente plus
de 90 % des émissions d'une entreprise
donc c'est vraiment sur ce scope 3 sur
ce périmètre là qu'il y a tous les
enjeux euh parce que c'est là qu'il a il
y a la majorité des émissions donc c'est
pour ça qu'on s'intéresse euh au au aux
projections sur le scope 3 et donc ce
qu'on voit c'est que euh si je vous
montre euh du coup euh la trajectoire et
ce sera peut-être plus clair entre 2023
et 2030 on voit euh une projection euh
de euh la production de gaz et de
pétrole euh de total donc vous pouvez
voir en haut euh où total prévoit d'être
euh d'ici à 2030 et où on a besoin
d'être si on suit les le scénario net Z2
euh de laie donc donc on voit qu'il y a
un très fort écart à horizon euh 2030
euh et donc sur la question de de donc
en fait toute la question c'est celle de
la trajectoire et on voit que les points
intermédiaires qu'on est censé
rencontrer si on suit les scénarios de
la UE ne sont pas au rendez-vous sur
cette stratégie si on s'intéresse aux
objectifs qui sont en 2050 donc là si on
regarde les émissions absolues euh on
peut voir que les émissions en fait
elles sont à peu près en accord avec les
scénarios de laie dans le sens où on a
bien une réduction une division par 4
des émissions liées à l'énergie à
horizon 2050 mais par contre on a des
définitions qui sont très ambigu et qui
sont pas alignés avec les standards de
référence notamment total parle d'être
net zéro or si on suit les standards que
sont le le la science base target qui
est une référence dans le secteur on
peut pas une entreprise ne peut pas se
déclarer net zéro en 2050 enfin elle
peut le faire si et seulement si elle a
réduit de 90 % ses émissions par rapport
à l'année de référence et si les
émissions incompressibles restantes
pardon ont été éliminé par des solutions
de de séquestration de carbone ce qu'on
voit sur les objectifs de Total énergie
c'est que il y a une réduction de ce que
de 75 % et en fait il y a une définition
très ambigue de de des émissions parce
qu'en fait qui sont supprimé parce qu'en
fait elle elle affiche une une
élimination des émissions restantes
grâce à des solutions qui ne sont pas
des des solutions d'élimination de
carbone excusez-moi mais des solutions
de d'évitement de carbone et donc on a
pas le droit de soustraire ces émissions
là dans la comptabilité euh dans la
comptabilité globale et enfin on voit en
bas quel mentionne une intensité carbone
en cycle de vie de - 100 % et ça pareil
dans la comptabilité on a on a on ne
peut pas parler d'une intensité de - 100
% on peut uniquement parler d'une
intensité en scope 1 2 3 mais sans
soustraire des émissions des émissions
éliminées donc ce que je voulais montrer
et le point que je voulais faire c'était
en fait le sujet principal c'est celui
de la
trajectoire donc on on on on est
d'accord sur le le point d'arrivée mais
toute la question c'est comment est-ce
qu'on y arrive et en fait quand on passe
par une trajectoire où on est au-dessus
de la courbe on aimit à horizon 2050
2030 pardon beaucoup plus d'émissions
qu'à horizon 2030 et donc c'est toutes
ces émissions supplémentaires qui sont
problématiques avec la question de
budget carbone et si je peux si je peux
me permettre oui très rapidement si je
peux me permettre de de de compléter sur
la réponse de loup à votre question
monsieur le rapporteur il y a aussi une
question qui est il y a un sujet qui est
qui est extrêmement important celui
qu'on appelle en économie donc c'est la
notion de lock in en économie et qui est
en fait le le la stratégie total
ennergie nous met face à une forme de
d'alternative ou d'arbitrage qui est
fondé sur deux axiomes le premier Axium
c'est que les infrastructures ce sont
des elles sont très intensives en
investissement donc elle requierent
beaucoup de ce qu'on appelle
effectivement le le CAPEX un
investissement et donc elles ont un
amortissement économique pardon qui est
très long dans le temps par ailleurs on
voit que totalénergie effectivement
continue à investir dans de nouvelles
infrastructures donc ça ça nous met face
à cette alternative à cet arbitrage
qu'on aimerait ne pas faire qui est soit
d'un côté on est face forcément à des
pertes économiques et financières très
importantes parce que ça veut dire que
ces infrastructures ne sont pas poussées
jusqu'à leur stade d'amortissement
prière solution deuxième solution ça
veut dire que sinon ça verrouille notre
trajectoire climatique bien au-delà des
budgets carbones 1 der5 ou ou 2 degr
très bien j'ai plusieurs demande
d'intervention commence par Monsieur
delè Merci monsieur le Président merci à
nos deux intervenants pour ces
éclairages je vous avoue que depuis le
début des des auditions je suis un peu
perdu parce queon nous abreuve
d'énormément de courbes de slid de
camamber on a un peu de mal à s'y
retrouver surtout si on n'est pas un
spécialiste de de ces questions là et
donc en vous entendant évoquer des étude
ne voyez pas malice dans ma question et
pas
forcément je dirais come on dit
maintenant du complotisme ou du
négationnisme enfin quand vous nous
parlez d'étude chinois
je me dis quels sont les éléments dont
vous disposez pour apprendre comme
argent comptant les conclusion de cette
étude si je pose la question c'est parce
que on vient de déposer à l'Assemblée
nationale une proposition de loi sur les
influences étrangères ici au Sénat on
vient de constituer une commission
d'enquête pas une mission d'information
mission
d'enquête sur les influence étrangère et
donc il me semble que dans les
présentations on peut pas d'un côté
avoir les vilains pétroliers et de
l'autre côté les gentilles ONG je pense
que c'est un petit peu plus compliqué
que ça et cette dimension des influences
étrangères ne peut pas me semble-t-il
être totalement exclu du débat que nous
avons donc ma question est simple quels
sont les moyens dont vous
disposez pour valider un certain nombre
de
données que vous nous avez présenté
aujourd'hui et qui servent à vos travaux
je vous
remercie merci Monsieur del je dois
reconnaître que quand vous avez cité une
étude chinoise tout à l'heure tout le
monde dans la salle se demandait ce que
c'était comme par définition monsieur je
vous rassure je ne suis pas sûr qu'
existe des ONG chinoises donc c'est
forcément une étude officielle mais
répondez d'accord alors donc j'ai cité
une étude chinoise qui a été promulguée
dans la revue Nature donc qui est quand
même assez validée par les paires je
pense le reste des études qu'on a cité
sont principalement donc vous avez à
chaque fois sur chaque slide la source
des informations euh notamment euh j'ai
principalement utilisé énormément de
graphi donc ce graphique là c'est moi
qui l' fait c'est pour ça qu'il y a pas
de source mais j'ai cité énormément de
sources de l'agence internationale de
laie qui est euh une agence dont les les
accords sont enfin dont les résultats
sont communément admis dans le monde
entier comme étant des scénarios de
référence pour des trajectoires de
décarbonation j'ai également cité
plusieurs chiffres qui proviennent
d'étude de Carbon 4at qui n'est pas une
ONG donc qui ne peut pas être taxé de
militantisme et en ce qui concerne le
chiffre que j'ai donné sur le GNL je
peux également vous en donner un
deuxième qui ne provient pas euh d'une
source chinoise si c'est c'est ce qui
vous inquiète euh pour vous confirmer la
l'autre chiffre bah un autre chiffre de
Carbon 4 qui a calculé que l'extraction
de gaz non conventionnel aux États-Unis
avait émis en 2020 plus de 40 % de
méthan supplémentairire par rapport à
l'extraction
conventionnelle donc et ce chiffre a été
calculé grâce à des 7 images satellites
qui
permettent de calculer assez précisément
ses émissions si vous voulez après
revenir dans le tail sur certains
graphiques mais je pense qu'on a
vraiment essayé d'utiliser l'art de la
science actuel et les définitions les
plus communément admises sur les sur les
scénarios de décarbonation et par
ailleurs si je peux me permettre
effectivement la la question la question
géopolitique et internationale elle est
extrêmement importante moi il me semble
que le vrai sujet plutôt que
effectivement cette étude par des
co-auteurs chinois publiés dans Nature
il me semble que la la vraie question
c'est plutôt la position de la France
enfin qu'est-ce que ça dit de
indépendance de l'autonomie stratégique
de la France d'être à ce point
dépendante d'importation d'énergie
fossile de l'étranger il me semble que
si on veut parler de de géopolitique
c'est plutôt ce sujet là que la question
de la publication des tir on rêverait
tous enfin non pas pas monsieur jade
mais on rêverait tous d'avoir encore du
pétrole et du gaz en France mais tant
qu'on en utilise on est obligé de
l'importer on n a pas donc je ne doute
pas qu'un jour on en aura plus besoin
mais enfin pour le moment jusqu'à preuve
du contraire nos voitures fonctionnent à
l'essence et on n a pas merci
oui évidemment en France on a pas de
pétrole mais on a beaucoup d'idées donc
on s'en sort ça fait 40 ans ou 50 ans
qu'on s'en sort comme ça merci monsieur
le Président merci mesdames merci pour
cette présentation votre travail honnête
et particulièrement pressé documenter
démontre parfaitement à quel point les
majeur de l'énergie comme Total ont une
trajectoire et ça fait plusieurs
auditions qu'on parle de trajectoire et
c'est peut-être ça qui est peut-être le
plus important donc c trajectoire
d'investissement qui sort clairement des
accords de Paris vous irmer s'il fallait
encore une nouvelle fois qu'il y a un
monde entre les déclarations de totale
énergie et les actes enfin en tout cas
ce qu'il faudrait faire pour aller dans
le bon sens en en tout cas celui qu'on
peut considérer comme étant le bon sens
les investissements dans le cadre des
bombes carbon risque de nous enfermer
dans un futur carboné incompatible avec
les engagements internationaux et
incompatible avec toute vie sur Terre
assez tranquillement euh ça a encore été
démontré sur ces auditions je retiens de
votre travail que les problme dépasse le
cas de Total énergie il y a beaucoup de
responsables les entreprises qui
exploitent les gisement mais aussi les
États qui les autorisent les banques qui
financent ses projets et d'ailleurs
beaucoup de de banques françaises même
mutualistes d'ailleurs c'est toute
l'économie capitaliste moderne hein on
peut le dire comme ça qui affiche sa
dépendance aux énergies fossiles donc
j'arrive à la question de quel outil
disposons-nous pour en sortir certains
pays ont-ils mis en place des
législations novatrices et ambitieuses
en la
matière en effet les États ont
évidemment un rôle central à jouer je
reviens pas sur le fait que la France
dépense chaque année 175 milliards
d'euros dans des aides sans conditions
ni contrepartie pour les entreprises
soit l'équivalent d'un/art du budget de
l'État et puis comme on sait clairement
que c'est pas au COP dans les cops que
ça se passe enfin voilà on en parle
beaucoup et à la fin il on il en ressort
pas énormément de choses je me demande
si c'est pas du côté plutôt de
l'Organisation mondiale du commerce il
faudra aller jeter un un cil parce que
on voit bien d'ailleurs graphique le
montit très clairement que c'est un
business que c'est un business
extrêmement juteux et que bah business
commerce un moment donné l'Organisation
Mondiale du Commerce a peut-être un
sujet à à regarder de ce côté-là
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ces
réflexions euh alors donc sur la il y a
plusieurs sousqus dans ce que vous dites
donc première question qui est
réglementation dans d'autres pays
deuxème question qu'est-ce que nous on
peut faire en France et dernière
question euh l'OCDE donc je commence par
les réglementations étrangères euh bon
globalement pas trop de surprise de ce
point de vue-là non il y a pas eu de de
réglementation absolument majeur qu'on
aurait raté dans d'autres pays même si
bon au groenlande au Danemark en
Équateur on note certaines formes de de
d'avancé réglementairire sur le sujet
euh je pense je pense pas que ce soit le
le la chose prioritaire sur laquelle se
concentrer parce que euh enfin
globalement c'est c'est pas vraiment par
cet angle- là je pense qu'on pourra
attaquer la question le l'autre partie
qui est très intéressante c'est
concrètement qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
euh donc il y a trois formes de levier
euh il y a trois manières dont l'État
peut
agir sur ces sur ces projets là donc et
et il a il y a l'une de ces manières qui
répond tout à fait à la question à cette
remarque que vous faisiez monsieur le
Président sur le fait que effectivement
on a toujours besoin actuellement de de
pétrole dans nos voitures et je pense
que ça ça nous permet de de développer
une réponse à ceci donc trois axes du
point de vue de la réglementation du
point de vue du rôle de l'État un
premier axe qui est agir sur l'offre
l'offre en énergie fossile un deuxième
axe qui est agir sur la demande et un
troisème axe c'est peut-être plutôt le
look qui complètera c'est agir sur les
investissement pardon je vous regarde
pas je reste pas à mon micro désolé a
euh pas de problème donc j'en reste sur
la baisse de l'offre donc quand on dit
BAE de l'ofre de quoi on parle c'est
comment est-ce que l'État peut jouer sur
la prod production d'énergie fossile
dans le monde et à forceori comment
est-ce que l'État français peut jouer
sur la production d'énergie fossile dans
le monde donc en particulier sur total
énergie il y a trois choses qu'on peut
dire à ce sujet là la première chose
c'est on pourrait imaginer que l'État
exige des plans de transition qui soient
contraignant des plans de transition
compatibles avec par exemple le scénario
le scénario de l'Agence internationale
de l'énergie ou un scénario accord de
Paris compatible donc ça c'est la
première chose et on pourra y revenir si
vous voulez la deuxième chose dont on
pourrait discuter c'est et et encore une
fois quand on parle de proposition de
réglementation nous ne sommes pas
parlementaires nous on on on pose des
idées évidemment tout ça relève de
décisions de discussions qui doivent
être politiques qui sont donc pas
complètement des préconisations de notre
part
mais la la deuxième proposition
c'est l'état pour avoir plus de poids
sur les activités de Total énergie on
pourrait imaginer une plus forte
détenenstion de la part d'état de l'état
du capital de Total énergie c'est-à-dire
le retour de l'État au capital de Total
énergie ça c'est aussi quelque chose
dont on pourrait parler c'est aussi une
proposition de réglementation qui
pourrait être mise sur la table de
réglementation encore une proposition
d'action publique qui pourrait être mise
sur la table pour renforcer le contrôle
public sur la stratégie de Total énergie
pour finir on pourrait aussi réfléchir à
à renforcer la loi sur le devoir de
vigilance la loi de 2017 qui est déjà
une une première bonne avancée
réglementaire qui av fait la
France l'une des pionnières en la
matière malgré tout malgré tout qui
n'empêche pas les atteintes à
l'environnement dont on a déjà largement
parlé ça c'est pour la baisse de l'offre
rapidement sur la baisse de la demande
quand je dis rapidement c'est aussi
parce que c'est un une question qui est
extrêmement vaste qui échappe au champ
de nos travaux à côté de cette baisse de
l'offre et pour répondre donc à votre
remarque monsieur le Président il faut
évidemment que l'État français joue
aussi sur la baisse de la demande donc
le fait qu'on ait moins besoin
d'hydrocarbures dans notre vie
quotidienne donc ça ça peut passer par
beaucoup de politiques publiques c'est
des politiques de de de décarbonation
sectorielle donc concrètement les les
solutions il y a déjà un large consensus
notamment porté par le Haut conseil sur
le climat sur cette question là c'est la
rénovation thmique des bâtiments c'est
des investissements dans des
infrastructures publiques notamment de
transport le rail enfin en gros financer
les alternatives vertes pour qu'on ait
moins besoin d'énergie fossile dans la
vie quotidienne et ça ça on pourra y
revenir mais c'est pas le l'objet exact
de la commission d'aujourd'hui ça passe
forcément par des politiques
d'investissement vert qui soient publ ou
privé encore une fois ça ça dépend de de
décisions de choix qui sont politiques
mais en tout cas pour résumer baisse de
l'offre agir sur la demande baisse de la
demande et pour finir un levier sur
lequel loup voudra peut-être compléter
le la réglementation des investissements
financiers oui pour compléter le
panorama avec la partie des
investissements on a vu l'importance du
financement
et de la possibilité d'existance de ces
projets grâce au financement notamment
et la responsabilité des acteurs
bancaires et financiers dans la
réalisation de ces projets donc on peut
envisager différentes choses d'abord au
niveau des projets eux-mêmes donc
d'interdire aux banques de financer des
nouveaux projets de charbon et
d'exploration et de production de
pétrôle et de gaz et ensuite on a une
partie aussi très importante par la
contribution aux négociations
européennes le sujet de relancer la
taxonomie brune donc l'idée c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a développé une
taxonomie enfin le but de la taxonomie
c'est vraiment de développer un langage
commun qui permette
d'identifier la contribution potentielle
des actifs à la transition énergétique
aujourd'hui au niveau européen on a
développé une taxonomie qui est verte
donc qui permet de d'identifier les
actifs qui contribuent positivement à la
transition mais par contre on n pas de
nouvelle de la taxonomie brune orors
celle-ci est essentiel puisque si on
fait simplement plus de verre on ne
règlera pas le problème climatique il
faut faire à la fois plus de verre et
moins de fossil et donc c'est en
identifiant ces actifs là qu'on pourra
également ensuite envisager de mettre en
place des mesures plus contraignantes
euh pour euh ne pas financer euh ou
beaucoup moins ces actifs là et euh on
peut aussi notamment penser du coup à
l'échelle plus nationale euh à la mise
en place du taux différencié qui a été
euh euh proposé qui a été évoqué
notamment par Emmanuel Macron et qui
permet euh de euh différencier le
financement des des produits verts en
rendant ce financement moins cher et
pareil pour le financement brun donc
pour le rendre plus compétitif le vert
merci compétitif le vert si si vous
voulez bien essayer de faire des
réponses plus précises et plus courtes
parce que sinon on va pas tenir j'ai
encore plusieurs demandes alors j'ai on
va peut-être prendre deux par deux si ça
vous embête pas parce que sinon on va
pas y arriver donc euh j'ai monsieur
tisso d'abord et puis ensuite se prépare
si je peux dire monsieur veissous fort
allez-y merci monsieur le Président ben
je vais être bref parce que d'ord merci
pour vos présentations claire précise
vous avez répondu à ma première question
qui portait sur l'offre et la demande de
quelle manière on pouvait on pouvait
régler ces questions là moi j'ai quand
même que pensez-vous quand même que des
des collisions qui peut y avoir entre
total et l'État et certains états comme
la Russie par exemple qui pose quand
même un problème d'ingérence
particulièrement avec ce pays-là et et
j'avais une autre deuxème question le 25
janvier dernier Laurence Laurence
Tubiana dans devant notre commission
nous indiquait que sur les 33 projets
superérémur total 19 sont situés à moins
de 50 km d'une zone de biodiversité
protégée avez-vous connaissance alors
c'est une question un peu simple mais
avez-vous connaissance des conséquences
directes de ces projets sur ces espaces
de biodiversité est-ce un impact
uniquement euh sur les émissions on va
dire globales mondiales et ça c'est la
première question et sur cette même
question quelles sont les réactions des
populations à votre connaissance les
populations locales vivant à côté de ces
bombes carbon je pense notamment au
projet d'extraction de gaz de schiste en
Argentine et l'Argentine qui est loin
d'être un état où il y a pas de
mobilisation sociale merci
oui merci monsieur le Président je
voulais moi aussi vous remercier pour
cet exposé extrêmement clair et
éclairant et et me semble-t-il très
utile euh je voulais euh revenir sur une
question que vous avez un petit peu
évoqué dans vos réponses madame
vellegrine c'est euh la question du rôle
important des des banques et des
assurances euh dans euh tous ces projets
euh des industries pétrolières la 13e
édition du rapport banking of clim et
Chao euh démontre que les banques
françaises ont alloué plus de 350
milliards de dollars aux énergies
fossile entre 2016 et 2021 il y a deux
banques qui battent des des records euh
en terme de financement des énergie
fossile même s'il ne faut pas oublier
que les banques américaines continuent
d'être celles qui financent le plus ces
énergies on peut imaginer que si on
réduisait euh
les les banques françaises enfin
l'impact des banques françaises ça
pourrait être récupéré par des banques
américaines néanmoins vous avez évoqué
les les possibilités de d'agir sur la
question de la réglementation peut-être
aussi sur la question de la transparence
qui pourrait être faite pour tous les
épargnants qui ne savent pas toujours
aussi euh dans quel quel leur épargne
quelquel projet elle finance
véritablement euh m'a j'ai cru voir
aussi que que la Banque Postale avait
annoncé en octobre
2021 qu'elle ne financerait plus les
projets énergétiques basés sur le
pétrole et le gaz qu'elle ne fournirait
plus aux acteurs des secteurs du pétrole
et du gaz de services financiers qu'elle
s'engageit à ne pas investir dans ses
entreprises et désinvestir
progressivement de ces entreprises
jusqu'en 2030 et à ne pas soutenir les
entreprises activement impliquées le
lobbying en faveur du pétrole ou du gaz
est-ce que c'est une réalité que vous
avez constaté est-ce que c'est un chemin
ou est-ce que finalement c'est une
banque qui intervient très peu dans ces
financements là et on reste plus sur un
effet d'annonce qu'une
réalité merci messieurs les sénateurs
pour vos questions je vais commencer par
répondre à la première je laisserai le
la deuxième à loup en tâchant d'être
effectivement la plus concise et claire
possible eu donc sur vos premières trois
questions monsieur le sénateur la
première collision entre total total
énergie et et l'État en particulier la
Russie la biodiversité et la réaction
des populations locales donc je commence
par la première les collusions entre
total et la Russie dans les informations
qui ont été portées à notre connaissance
on n pas d'élément particulierers sur la
collision entre total et la Russie ça
veut pas dire qu'il en a pas simplement
c'est hors du champ de notre travail en
revanche nous ce qu'on voit c'est que il
y a au moins deux projets de Total
énergie dans notre base de données donc
dans ces données-l qui sont qui sont
publiques C auxquels on avait accès donc
encore deux projets de Total en Russie
donc donc ça sans dire que ça montre qu'
qu'il y a des liens entre total et et
l'État russe ça veut dire en tout cas
qu'il y a encore des activités de Total
en Russie et ça ça peut faire ça peut
être une question à creuser
particulièrement ça c'était pour la
première question la deuxième
effectivement le chiffre de Madame
tbiana et est est très important
véridique une grande partie des projets
qui sont à proximité de zone de
biodiversité
protégé donc effectivement ce que vous
soullignez est juste ces projets de
bombe carbone n'ont pas seulement des
effets en terme d'émission mondiale mais
aussi à l'échelle micro à l'échelle
locale des effets qui peuvent être
dévastateurs sur la biodiversité Lou a
parlé tout à l'heure des effets de ce
qu'on appelle le fracking la fracture
hydraulique tant aux États-Unis que en
Argentine c'est un sujet qui est
absolument majeur qui déstabilise les
écosystèmes de manière générale euh même
un champ plus conventionnel ça a des des
effets qui sont certains sur la
biodiversité qu'elle soit marine ou
terrestre euh ça c'est une chose qui est
certaine la dernière partie de votre
question qui est la réaction des
populations locales alors de mon côté
moi j'ai j'ai pas à ma connaissance
d'éléments concernant la réaction des
populations locales en Argentine ce
queut pas dire qu'il en a pas à nouveau
en revanche je pense que il a été assez
documenté dans les dernières années même
si ce projet n'est pas une bombe carbone
mais le projet ECOP le East Africa crude
oil pipeline il y a une mobilisation en
Ouganda qui est qui est
particulièrement intense et qui montre
effectivement que les populations
locales ne sont pas toujours
suffisamment consultés ne sont pas
toujours intégrés dans les processus de
décision cela dit il faut avoir une
vision nuancée sur la question parce que
comme monsieur le Président vous le
souligner en introduction exploiter les
ressources pétrolières d'un pays ça
reste aussi un moyen d'accès au
développement et je pense qu'il est très
important de porter un regard qui soit
nuancé le plus nuancé possible sur ce
sujet je laisse lou répondre sur la
suite euh alors sur la partie des
investissements je précise quand même
que c'est pas du tout notre secteur
d'expertise
donc on je pense que vous allez
interviewer des gens qui seront qui
travaillent vraiment sur le sujet par la
suite qui auront des des
proposition plus précise mais je pense
que ce qui est important de rappeler
c'est vraiment ce qu'on a mentionné tout
à l'heure la différence entre le
financement direct au projet qui
représente d'après des chiffres de
reclaim finance à peu près 4 % des
financements et en fait le vrai sujet le
cœur du sujet qui est le financement
corporate donc c'est-à-dire quand une
banque finance directement une
entreprise qui elle-même euh va euh
faire euh et mettre en œuvre des projets
et donc ça ça représente 96 % en fait
des des des de la contribution des des
entreprises à ces projetslà et donc il y
a un un sujet à adresser donc à deux
niveaux le premier c'est comment est-ce
qu'on on empêche ces ces investisseurs
enfin ceses institution de d'investir
directement dans les nouveaux projets et
ensuite comment est-ce qu'elles peuvent
s'engager pour ne plus soutenir des
acteurs qui vont eux-mêmes développer
des nouveaux projets aujourd'hui il y a
très peu de banques en France qui se
sont engagées à ce niveau-là donc
notamment je crois la Banque Postale et
Arca qui se sont engagés à ne plus
financer d'entreprises qui qui mettaient
en place de nouveaux projets mais elles
sont très rares et donc toute la
question c'est comment est-ce que les
acteurs financiers
peuvent avoir des engagements et les
respecter de ne plus financer ces
projets là et sur le cas spécifique de
BNP je je ne connais pas suffisamment
leurs engagements précisément pour
pouvoir vous répondre
merci merci merci maintenant la parole
est à Monsieur fav puis s'il le veut
bien monsieur grevallet
oui monsieur le Président je voudrais
redescendre sur terre un petit peu pour
revenir sur ce qui nous a été présenté
euh bon on a présenté le l'état
d'avancement des connaissances que nous
avons des sites qui sont qui peuvent
constituer si SS sont exploités les
bombes carbon dont on nous a parlé
euh pour autant bon je crois que ça
c'est une connaissance qui qui est
déjà ancienne et et et
générale on nous a
également
indiqué que il y a avait des solutions
personnellement je suis sceptique déjà
depuis le début sur les dates qui nous
sont données
pour la suppression pratiquement de la
production de carbone sur la terre
entière je crois qu'actuellement il y a
trois pays qui à eux seul produisent à
peu près 60 % du gaz à effet de serre et
qui à ce jour continue à augmenter leur
production donc ne soyons pas même trop
euh trop naïf deuxème chose c'est une
question plus précise sur le
problème du résultat que pourrait
présenter pour nos pays la suppression
de l'exploitation des bombes à
carbone quels sont les ateliers
d'intive aujourd'hui à ma connaissance
euh on parle beaucoup en France des
énergies renouvelables
euh les énergies renouvelables si on les
prend une par
une non seulement actuellement elles
sont à un niveau qui ne permettrait pas
de palier mais admettons qu'à l'horizon
200 2050 l'ambition soit de palier les
besoins d'énergie sur le monde entier il
m'apparaît quant à moi que les énergies
renouvelables elles-mêmes sont porteuses
de production de carbone en quantité
importante puisque pour produire ces
énergies renouvelables la plupart ont
besoin de métaux qui sont des métaux
souvent rares souvent difficiles à
exploiter et l'exploitation de ces métau
elle-même est productive de beaucoup de
carbone donc j'aimerais qu'on me donne
une une présentation qui soit tout à
fait pragmatique de ce que peut-être à
l'horizon
2050 véritablement la production de
carbone sur notre bonne terre et et et à
ce moment-là je je regarderai les choses
avec un petit peu plus d'optimisme voilà
ma question monsieur le Président j'ai
été trop long malgré vos conseil
monsieur grvallet
oui je voulais juste dire qu'entre la
connaissance et la prise de conscience
il y a parfois un lapse de temps là on
l'a vu avec les travaux du sièc hein et
donc c'est un peu le sens de ma question
également on voit bien que depuis le
début des audition à la fois on est
évidemment sur un constat sur l'état des
lieux de de de la planète et à la
fois une constat sur l'état économique
de ce marché du pétrgaz qui dépasse
toutes nos frontières et un peu comme
les nuages toxiques et
donc la question est que sur ce type de
d'économie mondialisé il y a ce que l'on
peut faire dans nos frontières é tatiqu
encore sans doute et ce qui relève de la
régulation internationale et là on voit
que le chemin est long et puis il y a ce
qui relève de la prise de conscience et
donc de l'action citoyenne qui peut se
traduire au travers des ONG mais aussi
au travers des consommateurs que nous
sommes tous puisque si on veut agir sur
la demande et bien les consommateurs
sont responsables et notamment par
rapport auss système bancaire et qui
joue un rôle dans dans dans dans ce dans
ce jeu
international intermédiaire souvent
camouflé mais qui sont quand même euh
sans doute les plus sensibles à question
environnemental alors ma question est un
peu celle-ci comment sur ces trois
leviers quel est l'état des lieux sur
ces trois leviers et comment peut-on
agir plus pour que on ne soit pas à se
renvoyer la patate chaude si c'est pas
total c'est Chelle si c'est pas Chelle
c'est un autre et on a bien vu l'autre
jour dans le paysage que même ces major
n'occupaient qu'une petite place euh sur
les enjeux internationaux voilà donc ma
question est celle-ci quels sont
aujourd'hui les leviers les plus
efficaces pour agir et pour éviter que
ces bombes carbones nous explosent euh
pour les générations futures monsieur
Weber oui le le plus rapidement possible
tout à l'heure en commission affaires
euh européennes on a évoqué le traité de
la charte de l'énergie notamment la
sortie de la France de ce traité donc la
question je sais pas si c'est dans votre
champ d'étude mais quel est l'impact ou
l'analyse que vous portez sur
l'évolution du traité de la charte de
l'énergie en Europe et puis la deuxième
chose euh vous avez vous insistez sur
l'intérêt des signaux prix qui devrait
permettre d'évoluer théoriquement vers
un prix de l'énergie carbonée hein hors
taxe euh hors taxe faible pour désincer
la production et un prix TTC élevé pour
désinciter la consommation et donc quel
rôle joue ce signal prix notamment dans
le mixte énergétique français puisque
tout àhe vous avez parlé de la question
de l'offre et puis aussi à quel niveau
de taxe la major pétrro gazière est-elle
soumise est-ce que ça vous paraît
cohérent dans le cadre d'une économie de
transition quand on sait que l'Espagne
l'Italie ou le Royaume-Uni ont instauré
une taxe exceptionnelle sur les profits
des pétroliers suivant les
recommandations de l'ONU et de la
Commission européenne alors que la
France y refuse alors même qu'on a vu
que les chiffres apparus il y a quelques
jours montrait que les bénéfices de
Total avait continué à évoluer euh très
fortement on sera d'autant plus brève
euh donc sur la première question
peut-être que je laisserai loup
compléter sur donc le euh la transition
à partir de quand on a plus de fossil en
France et dans le monde quelles sont les
alternatives euh je comprends votre
question parce que c'est une
transformation qui est profondément
structurelle qui entraîne des des
bouleversements qui sont profonds
néanmoins il y a quand même un certain
nombre de scénarios au cours des années
qui ont été des dernières années qui ont
été produits qui montrent le fait que
c'est euh possible faisable et et
évidemment euh inévitable si on veut
préserver les conditions d'habitabilité
sur terre euh ça c'est pour la première
question la deuxième euh le constat sur
euh euh qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire dans
le cadre de nos frontières la
réglementation nationale on en a déjà
parlé sur la réglementation
internationale peut-être que c'est
intéressant de souligner le fait qu'il y
a déjà des standards internationaux qui
existent eu qui ont pas qui ont pas de
force contraignantes nécessairement il y
a des principes onusiens quand même euh
des principes de 2011 donc le le les
united nations guiding principles
notamment qui euh parle du devoir de
vigilance qui parle du devoir de due
diligence pour prévenir les atteintes
liées au comportement des entreprises
sur l'environnement sur les droits
humains même si ils sont pas
contraignants du point de vue juridique
dans la décision de Shelle que je
mentionnais tout à l'heure ces principes
sont cités à l'appui de la décision du
juge ce qui veut dire qu'il y a déjà un
début d'infrastructure juridique
internationale à la à la force normative
de plus en plus forte qui existe c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut renforcer ça
c'est la première chose la et et la
dernière chose effectivement l'action
citoyenne oui c'est important en
interaction avec le politique je pense
qu'on sait que c'est l'un des moyens de
d'arriver à des politiqu publique
climatique qui sont suffisamment
ambitieuses et pour finir très
brièvement sur le TCE effectivement la
France s'en est retirée à mes yeux c'est
une bonne chose reste le fait que il y a
une clause dans mon souvenir on n pas
réussi à neutraliser ce qu'on appelle la
sunset clause la clause de de dein qui
couvre après la sortie du traité qui
dans mon souvenir dure 20 ans qui nous
engage donc toujours aux dispositions du
traité par ouais par ailleurs l'Union
européenne pour l'instant n'a pas encore
réussi à faire aboutir les négociations
qui visent à faire sortir l'Union
européenne de ce traité c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut poursuivre qui est
nécessaire aussi et le prix du carbone
effectivement bon en théorie classique
économique le prix du carbone c'est
quelque chose qui est absolument
essentiel je terminerai juste en disant
que effectivement la taxe carbone si on
veut réussir à s'en sortir avec ce
triangle d'incompatibilité entre donc
ambition des politiques climatiques
faisabilité budgétaire et acceptabilité
sociale il ne faut pas oublier le fait
que la taxe carbone pour éviter des
mouvements comme celui des gilets jaunes
dans les dernières années doit inclure
ce qu'on appelle du recyclage
c'est-à-dire une partie du transfert de
la recette vers les ménages pour
s'assurer de la de la l'acceptabilité
socioppolitique de cette mesure je
m'arrête là et je laisse le
compléter pour être très brève également
sur la question de de des scénarios et
de la date enfin de votre questionnement
sur les scénarios je pense que
aujourd'hui on a quand même atteint un
consensus mondialement partagé à travers
notamment les les travaux du GC mais
également les la la reconnaissance des
scénarios de l'agence internationale de
laie qui du coup table à horizon 2050
donc qui vraiment qui chiffre euh de
combien est-ce qu'il faut réduire
l'énergie fossile donc il faut diviser
par 4 et le budget carbone il a été
calculé par un consensus scientifique de
milliers de scientifiques dans le mond
monde donc je pense qu'on est en mesure
de considérer ces scénarios comme étant
la référence qu'on doit utiliser pour
pour calculer l'avenir et les
trajectoires dans lesquelles on veut se
projeter si on veut avoir une chance de
rester sous les 1.5 je pense que ce qui
est important de rappeler c'est vraiment
que chaque 10è de degré supplémentaire
au-delà de C 1.5 génère des conséquences
beaucoup plus élevées et qu'il y a des
effets de cliqué du climat qu'on
déclenche qui fait que à un certain
moment le réchauffement climatique
s'autoalimente et que les conséquences
deviennent incontrôlables et des
conséquences incontrôlables ça veut dire
qu'on est plus capable de maintenir une
société qui qui est pérenne sur les
alternatives euh les le donc l'agence
internationale de laie émet également
des recommandations sur comment
atteindre c'est ce ce budget carbone
réduit principalement en allant très
vite développer massivement les énergies
renouvelables et donc il faut augmenter
énormément les investissements donc il
faut que pour un dollar dans le fossile
on est investi 6 dans le renouvelable
euh le l'Agence internationale table
énormément également sur l'efficacité
énergétique et enfin euh on n arrivera
pas sans mesure de sobriété donc il va
falloir aussi réduire euh notre
consommation euh et la demande de
manière globale je pense que pour
prendre un peu de la hauteur le sujet
principal en fait ici on parle si on on
revient sur le cas de la France euh la
question c'est pas qui va continuer
est-ce que c'est total est-ce que c'est
Chelle et cetera la question c'est celle
de la résilience de la France dans les
années à venir et ce sverer du du du
fossile vous l'avez dit vous-même on a
pas de pétrole dans le sol c'est aussi
assurer notre souveraineté c'est aussi
être plus indépendant par rapport euh au
reste du monde en ce qui concerne notre
consommation énergétique voilà
merci merci Madame merci de cette
audition et je demande à mes collègues
évidment de rester puisque nous avons
une 2è audition ensuite merci mesdames